I'm Jimmy phela I'm Madison allworth I'm
Bill hemmer and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday April 19 2023 I'm Jessica
Rosenthal another deep dive into covid's
Origins this one from Senate Republicans
also concludes it was likely an
accidental lab leak that sparked the
pandemic and that it all happened
earlier than we thought the
preponderance of evidence shows that
this virus was accidentally released
from a laboratory in Wuhan China if they
want to own it or not you know they're
playing political games we speak with
Kansas Republican senator Roger Marshall
I'm Dave Anthony it's been 30 years now
since an FBI raid on a compound in Waco
Texas turned deadly ending a 51-day
Siege we talked to a retired ATF agent
who is at the first raid that started it
all the first shot I heard was clearly
came from inside the compound you know
it was a muffled kind of a shot but it
was immediately followed by dozens and
then quickly thrown into hundreds of
shots and I'm Greg Jarrett I've got the
final word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
a report compiled by doctors along with
the gop's help committee staff and
released by Kansas Republican senator
Roger Marshall concludes covid likely
originated from the Wuhan Institute of
virology in China and was accidentally
released the FBI and Department of
energy came to the same conclusion but
this 300-page report now public
Aggregates all the details including
reports about a bad flu season around
Wuhan beginning as early as October of
2019 an order for new HVAC equipment for
a part of the lab in September of 2019.
a Chinese government drill in Wuhan
quote at its International Airport that
included identifying and responding to
an arriving passenger infected with a
novel coronavirus also in September of
2019. the report dives into the genetic
sequence of the virus the type of
research the Wuhan Institute was
conducting that it was well known the
concerns about safety at the lab
preceding the pandemic and numerous
other details the report dropped as the
house oversight and accountability
select subcommittee on the coronavirus
pandemic began a hearing on the matter
chaired by Ohio Republican Congressman
Brad wenstrup what is clear though is
that China does not want the globe to
know the origins
they Dodge and duck every legitimate
attempt to investigate this question
according to the fact sheet China has
systematically prevented a transparent
and thorough investigation of the
covid-19 pandemic's origin Democrats
like ranking member Raul Ruiz of
Maryland reminded the committee that
most U.S agencies still believe covet
has a natural origin and likely did not
leak from a lab as it stands there is no
consensus the reports are inconclusive
and more research is needed
while our scientists and intelligence
communities continue their
investigations it is crucial that we
Empower them to do so without extreme
partisan rhetoric however according to
the star witness former Director of
National Intelligence John Ratcliffe the
only theory that makes sense is a lab
leak and the new Senate GOP report
concurs so this is a committee report
from the GOP help folks Kansas
Republican senator Roger Marshall what
it showed is there's a preponderance of
evidence that supports that this virus
and this epidemic started from a
laboratory in Wuhan China that it was an
accidental lab leak I in fact there was
probably two leaks one in probably
September 2019 they were able to contain
that they began doing research on the
vaccine in November of 2019 and that's
probably when the more significant leak
occurred that led to the worldwide
pandemic that killed millions of people
secondly there's significant evidence to
support that this virus was made in one
of those Laboratories and finally this
report really dispels the thought that
this could have come from nature that
when a virus comes from nature a natural
spillover event it should have left a
trail a footprint and this virus didn't
do that we've waited three years on
China to show us more data they continue
to hide it including a DNA lab bank but
that's the Highlight this virus was an
accidental release from a laboratory in
Wuhan China most likely was made in that
laboratory and this theory of the
natural spillover just doesn't have much
legs to stand on you're a medical doctor
for for those of us who are not what did
you find to be maybe or perhaps the most
compelling evidence like was it the way
the virus itself looked was it that
people who'd worked at that lab had been
hospitalized or was it something
entirely new right I think it's the
preponderance of evidence that I would
emphasize again as a physician I'm an OB
GYN if I have a patient with a problem
I'd get consultations so in this
particular case we we call in the
intelligence committee let's look at all
the intelligence reports why are they
setting up roadblocks around this Wuhan
lab in September October of 2019 why is
all the other decreased cell phone
activity going on uh next is the
epidemiology of it the epidemiology of
this fits more with an accidental lab
release than it does something from from
nature neck I would talk about the the
science of this that the day this virus
showed up it was perfectly made to
infect human lung cells what do you
conclude as the significance for the
lack of information you know former head
of intelligence John Ratcliffe told a
house hearing Tuesday you know we don't
have an environmental Source identified
we don't have an intermediate host there
is no Reservoir species identified
um and covet was never known to have
existed in any animal or species before
it began how significant is is that the
missing information
well I think it's very significant and
Radcliffe makes a great point when we
when you set up this Theory and that's
what we do as scientists we say here's
the theory let's let's say this came
from nature and it was a natural
spillover there should be evidence like
you just described the reservoir they
should be able to find the bats where
this came from the next they should have
been able to find an intermediate
species and to date not one animal has
tested positive for this that was from
the same Market there where they said
that this virus started from and it's
the lack of showing us the DNA if they
open their books and they've got it this
is these people's life where Dr she her
life's work was playing with these virus
they went around the world collecting
bat viruses and they were playing with
them they were taking off protein spikes
from one virus adding it to another
backbone and they were doing it in
biosecurity levels Labs two and three
which are just this is the wrong place
to do it that just scares me to death as
a scientist but you're right if they
would show us all that information that
they would show us what viruses they
were breeding to one another I'm sure it
would show us exactly where covid-19
came from we know agencies are
investigating covet Origins
um and most of them have concluded with
low confidence that they still think
this was a natural occurrence despite
the FBI and Department of energy saying
that they think it came from a lab how
does your report fit into to all of this
did you pull from some of these agencies
findings did you gather wholly separate
new information uh so all the above so
certainly the the folks I want to give
Dr Bob cadlett credit for leading this
charge he looked at classified
information he looked at unclassified
information for you information anything
and everything that we could get our
hands on uh look the FBI and the doe
Department of energy are uniquely
situated to give an opinion which I
would agree with because they have the
scientist and they can go talk to
Witnesses especially the FBI so they had
to talk to scientists who understand
this I think there's a handful of the
agencies would have said they don't have
an opinion one way or the other and to
be honest they're a bunch of gutless
Wonders that they're not willing to make
a statement that they're afraid it'll be
politicized I think again the
preponderance of evidence shows that
this virus was accidentally released
from a laboratory in Wuhan China if they
want to own it or not you know they're
playing political games at the house
here on Tuesday Dr Mark lowenthal the
minority witness he told lawmakers you
know we just may never know we have to
recognize that so many agencies our own
intelligence agencies still think this
occurred naturally even if doe and FBI
have more uniquely qualified people to
make that assessment but is there a way
in your mind after you've compiled this
report is there a way to come to a
totally solid conclusion where there's
no doubt
without help from China if we don't have
the evidence and we don't have the
cooperation we may never get it can we
still come to a more solid conclusion so
Jessica that's a cop-out there is
certainly enough evidence that we would
get a conviction in a civil case Okay uh
even just China's deep scrolling of
evidence and killing Witnesses uh all
these witnesses that would be help are
are dying the person that was working on
the vaccine for China he's mysteriously
died in June of 2020 as well to get a
criminal conviction beyond the shadow of
that you know I don't think so not
unless China is willing to cooperate but
that does not excuse the United States
government from doing what we're doing
why in the world would we be giving
money to Laboratories in Wuhan China to
do research that's more powerful that's
killed more people than nuclear bombs
have then we don't if properly monitor
it we don't have scientists over there
there's so much to learn from this
regardless if we can prove it beyond a
shadow of a doubt but I really do think
that this report shows the preponderance
of evidence says that this virus was an
unintentional lab leak in Wuhan China we
know Chinese officials say any
conclusion that this came from a lab is
politicized political manipulation is
there fear here regarding consequence
like what what would or could
consequences be and should they be if
this is the case
right so I call this the gain a function
Mafia uh led by Dr fauci and Dr Collins
that they in this group of scientists
for 20 years have spent billions of
dollars I mean your listeners need to
understand facio bersal a six billion
dollar a year industry of awarding grant
money and he was able to leverage that
with the Clinton foundation and Gates
Foundation monies as well then he would
leverage it with the Department of
Defense monies and usaid monies equal
health is the middle of this gain of
function uh Mafia as well so the
consequences is that we end this game of
spending billions of dollars that's
actually killed millions of people and
has given us no benefit so you know the
gig the jigs up so to speak I think
that's part of it and then politically
uh you know the United States has to own
this as well that we were again
financing this for years we and and more
than just financing it we gave them the
intellectual property we taught them how
to put on these protein spikes taken
from one virus and putting it on another
other we taught them how to use this
urine cleavage site as well so it's the
intellectual property it's the money and
the fear is this the PLA and the CCP are
are intertwined so much in this research
and China itself says look this is a
bioterrorism weapon that they have
concerns for their National Security and
they're going to respond to that threat
by developing countermeasures as well as
offensive measures so as China goes
about this process of collecting the DNA
of every human every plant and every
animal in the world there's good things
they can do that with that and there's
bad things they can do with it so
Senator then what do you say when to Dr
fauci Who says this is just a flat out
lie we we're not funding gain of
function research there I mean he I
think it was even referenced in the
house hearing Tuesday that that um that
he told Rand Paul he told senator Paul
you know no such thing occurred even if
Eco Health Alliance did get some grant
money and was working with the Wuhan lab
that that these flat denials from the
folks that were in charge of NIH right
so even the NIH is now calling this gain
of function research
and our document illustrates exactly
when they decided that the what they
were funding with Eco Health was gain of
function research it's a year five Grant
report that was submitted about a year
late and then they even changed the gain
of function so this this is the point
the NIH has manipulated the gain of
function research definition the suit
whatever it darn well fed them and what
they thought it needed to be and even
today we're continued to fund bioagata
function research in China as well as
some of our own Laboratories and we need
to stop it until we get our hands around
it so I think that no one in America is
going to sit there and believe Dr fauci
when he says this was not gain a
function research it clearly was that
meets the classic definition of making a
virus more transmissible as well as more
virulent that's exactly what stars cov2
was and they're continuing to do it in
China and I'm afraid even in
Laboratories in America as we speak
Senator Marshall thank you so much for
joining us thanks so much me
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Greg Jarrett with your Fox News
commentary coming up
April 19th is an Infamous day to critics
of the U.S government because of what
happened 30 years ago the FBI conducted
a raid in Waco Texas to end a 51-day
Siege at the Branch Davidian compound
but as they went in and fired tear gas
fires broke out and 76 people inside
were killed including the religious sex
leader and 22 kids the offender there
was David koresh
and and I do not think the United States
government is responsible for the fact
that a bunch of Fanatics decided to kill
themselves and I'm sorry that they
killed their children former President
Clinton was in office at the time but
some claim including Branch Duty and
survivors the FBI was to blame after
botching negotiations to end the
standoff peacefully the FBI and ATF were
brought to task in front of Congress and
the American people that's from a new
Fox Nation special called scandalous
Waco after all the hearings trials and
media coverage what happened at Waco
remains hotly debated so is how it all
started
that is the sound of the first raid that
led to the Siege when the ATF tried to
arrest the leader koresh who was accused
of sexually assaulting girls and having
an arsenal of weapons Mary seldom does
the day go by they don't think about
those events Blake Butler was there that
day he's now a retired ATF senior
special agent I think about the cost the
human cost in lives and not only just
from the Branch Davidian sides and the
ATF agents that were killed but when you
look at the Oklahoma City bombing that
Timothy McVeigh did just two years to
the day after April 19th when the
compound burned 168 more people were
killed and uh the way it's affected and
polarized people in the United States
over these past 30 years let's go back
to how it all started it was February 28
of 1993 and you guys conducted a raid on
this compound what happened we drove
down you know from Fort Hood to Waco
early early that morning we had notified
an ambulance service and uh one of the
people in the ambulance service notified
the media that we were in the process of
doing this warrant and one of the media
people was out there driving around
early that morning around nine o'clock
and got lost and when they located a
rural Postman there they asked them
where the Branch Davidians were and that
Postman turned out to be a Branch
Davidian and he told them the ATF and
the National Guard were serving the
warrant so he went back and told David
koresh that uh ATF and the National
Guard were coming and we had an
undercover agent in there at the time
who came out and alerted uh our Command
Staff that hey they know we're coming
and tactical Commander came in and said
hey he knows we're coming he's shaking
he's holding the Bible he said they got
me once they'll never get me again but I
think we can still do this thing is what
he said so most of us were like in shop
thinking well if they know we're coming
why are we going forward with this since
the element of surprise is critical in a
dynamic entry such as we were planning
right um and they know that they know
their compound so they can be ready at
any spot yeah and that's absolutely what
happened uh unbeknownst to us all their
weapons had already been handed out we
were under the false premise that the
weapons were all locked up in a Gun Room
which was the way it had been many
months before but since uh Child
Protective Services had already been
investigating correction talking to him
about him molesting and raping the young
girls he was on notice that eventually
we would be coming and so they'd handed
out the guns so in that 46 minutes
between the time that koresh was
notified that we were coming and the
time that we actually arrived there they
had 46 minutes to get everything planned
to get their guns get to their windows
and wait for our arrival so then what
happens you show up in what
so uh as we pull down into the compound
uh and we stopped it's just as soon as
the doors opened up the gunfire started
and I the first shot I heard was clearly
came from inside the compound you know
it was a muffled kind of a shot but it
was immediately followed by dozens and
then quickly thrown into hundreds of
shots you know one of the big things
that I've been asked Dave is a lot is
you know who who fired first who fired
first that's the big question and of
course the Davidians say that ATF fired
first and you know where's ATF we say
well we're certain that they fired first
but there were some objective people out
there that morning and those were the
reporters from KWTX and uh reporters
from the Waco Tribune Herald and to the
man each one of them in their statements
stated that the Branch Davidians fired
first and that they ambushed ATF four
agents were killed
I believe six Branch Davidians were
killed yo this gunfighted lasted 112
minutes wow um most yes most law
enforcement gunfights I think on average
are somewhere around seven seconds I
think the Texas Rangers estimated that
ATF fired around 1100 rounds of
ammunition in that time period and the
Branch Davidians fired 10 000 rounds uh
so how did only four agents get hit well
you know we'd like to think God was on
our side in that respect uh sadly we
lost four guys but how we didn't lose
more we don't know many agents were shot
in the head that had helmets and so the
the bullets Ric shade off the helmets we
had one agent who had a a backup pistol
over his chest and around hit that
backed up pistol had it not hit the
pistol and gone two inches higher it
would have gone through his chest and
killed him what about you did you get a
bullet near you the bullets were
everywhere I saw an agent that was I
couldn't tell if he was dead or wounded
to the left of the front doors at this
time and several agents would move into
positions of cover to the right and so I
was giving them some cover fire someone
in a window above with a machine gun
fired down on me and then raked the
sidewalk in front of me and it
splattered my face with uh concrete and
bullet shrapnel so it just nicked my
face I wouldn't even call it being
wounded uh but then I had to move to a
position of cover after that so you are
lucky
no and I think uh I think we're lucky if
you want to call it that uh looked after
uh however you want to perceive it but
yeah many people were lucky that day uh
some of the misconceptions you know
people believe that ATF at that time was
that we were armed with machine guns and
that we were this heavily armed group
when in fact almost half of the agents
were only armed with a nine millimeter
pistol no agents had fully automatic
machine guns none we did not come
looking for a gun fight we came looking
to serve this lawful search warrant for
machine guns and Hand Grenades and an
arrest warrant for David koresh uh for
the possession of those what if you
didn't go in I mean you said the
commander said we can your commander
thought you could do it yeah well that's
right you know in their initial planning
phase that we we discussed what was the
best plan was it to do a dynamic warrant
service which is what we tried that
morning or do we do what ended up
happening which was a Siege and the
reason that we moved away from The Siege
concept was that they had months if not
years of food inside the compound and
all the people that we interviewed that
had come out of there said that if you
surround them
trap them in there they will commit mass
suicide and in the end 51 days later
that's exactly what they did they uh
they lit The Compound on fire when they
thought that the FBI was coming in and
they killed themselves of course Branch
Davidian survivors and government
critics dispute that they blame the FBI
and attorney general Janet Reno her
testimony is included in the Fox Nation
Waco special the plan was designed to
induce serious negotiations or the
evacuation of the compound with
extremely limited risk that agents would
harm any of the occupants or be harmed
themselves
we announced repeatedly
to those within the compound that there
would be no attempt to enter the
compound by federal agents some claim
tear gas the FBI fired into the compound
could have started those fires they had
agreed in their gas plan that if the
branch division started shooting at the
tanks potentially going to try to shoot
the agents that they would then put in
all the gas that they had so that's when
they fired what they call CS ferret
rounds and these are 40 millimeter
rounds that are fired from a little
handheld gun now what happens is these
things
go through the windows and then they hit
the wall and then they crack open and
that it's not really powder it's more
like particles come out okay
um they're non-flammable at all this
stuff is what we call blast dispersion
it hits the wall and then breaks apart
and then the particles spread around as
the wind blows through and things like
that okay but when they're launched is
is any of the material the casing
anything isn't hot
could it spark anything the main
building only had the regular CS blast
dispersion canisters they don't have
anything that can start a fire at all
law enforcement every day in America
uses CS gas on barricaded suspects that
are in houses things like that uh you
know the Branch Davidians had 51 days to
come out but they never would
um it could have gone on potentially for
months maybe even a year so they were
hopeful that the gas would make things
uncomfortable and that they would knock
holes in the wall and the branch
divisions would be able to leave but
that is not what happened is you can
hear on some of the tapes when they see
the gasket and they say put on your
masks put on your masks so they want to
stay in there and then you can also hear
them say spread the fuel I need more
fuel over here and then the fires start
and if you'll know there's three
different points of origin that the fire
starts almost simultaneously that are
quite a distance from one another so
that's indicative of people purposely
starting fires in different locations in
the building they have a
Branch Davidian survivors Waco group on
Facebook and they warn members they
warned people not to trust anybody and
media who's trying to look into this 30
years later they say trust no one you
know they they still believe you as the
government you working for the ATF and
then later the FBI were always the
aggressors you try to go in on February
28th then you then you go in on April 19
and they say you killed all these people
and these kids it's still the message
and and people have as you pointed out
Timothy McVeigh people who believe that
the government is the aggressor have
used that against the government in the
years since
you know all I can do is speak the facts
that I know that I lived through and
that I've seen and uh it's pretty clear
what happened you know in the end one of
the questions I'm always asked is you
know is well do you believe David koresh
really thought that he was the Messiah
or do you just believe he was a con man
in my opinion he's a guy that believed
that he didn't want to go to prison for
being a pedophile and being a guy in
possession of all these machine guns
Blake Butler retired ATF senior special
agent and Special Response Team
Commander also part of the scandalous
Waco special on Fox Nation there are
three episodes there and Blake of course
was there for what happened at the start
of the 51-day siege 30 years ago Blake
thanks very much for joining us
having me Dave
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi do
you live in a big city and feel like
your dollar doesn't go as far as it
should you might be on to something
according to a new study by smart asset
uh investment advisor company the
average American would need to earn at
least three hundred thousand dollars per
year to meet the demands and cost of
living in cities like New York and
Honolulu it's a huge leap from just five
years ago when a six-figure salary was
considered an important milestone for
workers in New York City a one hundred
thousand dollar salary amounts to about
791 dollars when you consider taxes and
cost of living Honolulu it amounts to 36
026 bucks San Francisco takes the spot
for third priciest City by contrast the
cities that go the farthest on a one
hundred thousand dollar salary include
Memphis Tennessee we're going to bounce
to more than eighty six thousand dollars
after taxes and cost of living seven of
the top 10 cities are in Texas with El
Paso taking the second spot and Houston
in 6 place for the Fox News rundown I'm
Gianna jalosi
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
I'm Dana Perino join me for season three
of my limited time podcast everything
will be okay based on my best-selling
book of the same name make sure you
subscribe to this series wherever you
download podcasts and leave a rating and
review subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary Greg Jarrett what's
on your mind Joe Biden's history as a
serial fabulous exceeds even today's
shameful standards of Habitual line in
Washington the president's repeated
insistence that he never discussed with
Hunter is overseas business dealings let
alone with his Partners is belied by
indisputable evidence that has grown
exponentially over time yet the elderby
maintains the ludicrous charade recently
Fox News uncovered records showing that
Hunter's Associates in his suspected
influence peddling schemes
frequented the White House more than 80
times when his father was vice president
Biden's persistent claim that he had no
knowledge of his son's foreign dealings
then never spoke with him about it
defies logic and Common Sense even
Hunter disputes it admitting to the New
Yorker that he did talk with his father
about his lucrative Venture in Ukraine
that netted some 11 million dollars an
audio tape surfaced in which Joe Biden
has heard discussing a pending news
article about his son suspicious Chinese
deals and informing his son I think
you're clear
authenticated emails confirmed that Joe
Biden attended numerous meetings and
dinners with many of Hunter's foreign
investors and business partners
photographs corroborated and there are
messages thanking Hunter for arranging
meetings with his dad the two flew to
China together aboard Air Force two
where Joe met with his son's business
cohorts just Days Later Hunter cemented
a lucrative Venture with a Beijing
investment firm
the entwining of Biden's finances with
foreign adversaries raises great
concerns about National Security
counterintelligence and potential
extortion of our current president have
our country's defense and economic
Interest been jeopardized it seems so
this is precisely why republican-led
congressional committees are now
investigating what Democrats refuse to
probe the role of Congress is all the
more vital because it's clear that both
the FBI and the doj are running
interference to the bidens despite
written demands by members of Congress
attorney general Merrick Garland refuses
to appoint a special counsel while
ignoring regulations that require him to
recuse himself the FBI has had custody
of Hunter's computer hard drive for four
years it appears to have been buried
deep in a vault never to see the light
of death meanwhile the U.S attorney in
Delaware has been investigating for five
years not a single charge has been
brought despite incriminating evidence
none is expected the accumulated
evidence of wrongdoing is overwhelming
emails witness statements visitor logs
and other records make it abundantly
clear that Jill Biden was complicit in
his son's Shady multi-million dollar
influence peddling operations
with much of the government bureaucracy
aligned in solidarity to protect the
president and his family Congress is now
the only Avenue by which the truth can
be unraveled I'm Greg Jarrett for Fox
News
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad-free on
Fox News podcasts Plus on Apple podcast
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
hey it's Will Kane co-host of Fox and
Friends Weekend join me as I share my
thoughts on a wide range of topics from
Sports and pop culture to politics and
business so will Cain podcast subscribe
and listen now at foxnewspodcasts.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and
a Pinterest and click the Fox News
rundown playlist for the latest episodes